[Music]
did I read that you you traced your
roots it was for a TV show recent was a
PBS show it was a PBS you trace your
roots well okay I didn't I didn't do the
legwork everything I just you know gave
him my name and they ran with it
yeah dr. Henry Louis Gates he doesn't
show finding roots on PBS and so yeah
they did this this this my whole family
they would they will it just just a one
my father's mother's side they were able
to go back to 1650 yeah which is like I
am like the the from what he said I am
the the only african-american that he's
been able to go back that far yeah
- like 1650 in Virginia and and it's
because my ninth great-grandmother
Elizabeth Banks she was a white woman
and they think from Scotland and she
came over here as an indentured servant
and she got down with a slave yeah oh
yeah yeah so so so and were there were
repercussions for this or no it was it
was I don't even know how that would
insects Gini repercussions white woman
having sex with a slave I'm pretty short
it was some you know brouhaha going on
yeah actually she was punished they they
saw the wreck we saw the record where
she got 39 lashes
you're kidding yeah 39 lashes and she
was charged with bastardy you know for
having his baby and but because she was
free the baby was free so because it's
the condition of the mother so our whole
line you know they you are you were as
far back as infinity free Negroes yes so
that explains why I'm so uppity she's a
white woman so it also explains why I
love white women these are powerful
genes you're talking about in G's
reasons were you this outspoken always
when you were a kid were you this
outspoken if you always just but it
wasn't always a good thing especially
know as a kid I got in a lot of trouble
especially for my parents because you
know I would just say whatever just you
know just I will see something and say
it but the problem is I didn't have you
know I just had all set up no punchlines
you know I was like I was like a friend
will come over my father and I'm sitting
there my boy you you're going ball right
here I don't have the boy your soul ball
your blood I just hate just put they'll
pawn yeah you know that'd be great to do
that tonight come back though
hey you're fine no your balls okay
everybody
[Laughter]
so they wouldn't yes but it was shipped
me off to my grandmother's house and get
me away because they didn't want me to
come he came over there if you just get
rid of me because they didn't know what
I was saying you know it's kind of like
how the White House treats a little Jill
Biden about the door companies come the
window throat was sandwich out the door
and he goes